ja
habt ihr euch auch schon mal gefragt wie
viel bier beim oktoberfest eigentlich
verschüttet wird wenn man wein nicht aus
viel zu großen weingläsern sondern aus
biergläsern trinken würde dann wäre das
der unkultiviert dann wäre das eine
große sauerei weil sein vielleicht
überschwappt als bier selbst wenn man
das glas nicht bis ganz oben hin voll
macht und zwar ist das folgendermaßen
wenn man mit einem getränk in der hand
ein stoß bekommt dann wird das getränk
zunächst zu einer seite hin aus gelenkt
und wird dann durch die schwerkraft
wieder nach unten oder zurückgezogen und
schwingt dann wie ein pendel hin und her
die flüssigkeit erhält durch den stoß
eine sogenannte potenzielle energie die
anschließend in bewegungs und reifens
energie umgewandelt wird bis die
flüssigkeit zum stillstand kommt sobald
ich aber schaue auf dem gerät befindet
und dazu reichen auch nur wenige
millimeter schau geht das hin und her
sparten viel schneller abgebremst dank
sogenannter kapillare kräfte kapillare
kräfte wirken der schwerkraft entgegen
und könnt ihr eigentlich bei jedem glas
wasser beobachten wenn ihr genau
hinschaut sie die amerikanische den
sogenannten meniskus das ist da wo das
wasser sich am glasrand so hoch zieht
schau besteht ja aus hoch gläschen
luftbläschen sind luft eingepackt in
dünne flüssigkeit wende wenn schaum in
einem glas ist dann kommt das glas mit
ganz vielen den flüssigkeits ländern in
kontakt die kapillare kräfte zwischen
gas und flüssigkeit wirken wie gesagt
der schwerkraft entgegen und damit wie
eine bremse
dieses wissen könnt ihr natürlich jetzt
auch auf andere getränke übertragen wenn
ihr zb so wie ich zu den menschen gehört
die sich regelmäßig mit kaffee
überschütten sehr unkultiviert dann wäre
es sinnvoll auf cappuccino umzusteigen
schön schlosscafé wenn ihr wissen wollt
bani am besten morgen freuen kaffee
trinkt oder wenn ihr wissen wollt was
schwerkraft mit astronauten und rücken
zu tun hat dann klickt hier trieben und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren um jede
woche etwas neues zu lernen